thomas and jennifer are investigating
one of tutankhamun's secrets
excavating under a ruined fortress for
evidence he got his gold from the
inhospitable eastern desert
did his miners shelter here
the team has just found something
stone blocks that offer a tantalizing
glimpse of a settlement from
tutankhamun's time
so these are architectural blocks they
carry some hieroglyphic
inscription very faintly visible here
which would indicate that they were
carved
and set up in some sort of building
which dates to the reign of tutankhamun
it's exciting because that gives us a
sort of a ballpark for the time when
this site was busy and active and
important during the 18th dynasty
jennifer's team must now move the
precious blocks off-site for further
analysis
as they dig deeper into the layers below
the fortress
they uncover more clues that this site
was in use in tutankhamun's time
it is beautiful
this is a really
distinctive very different from any of
the ptolemaic material the greek style
pottery that we find in most of the
rooms of the fort that is is really
common
this kind of pottery which belongs to
the new kingdom is not wheel made it's
handmade and you can tell that by
looking at the interior of the pot which
has a surface which is very irregular
and that it's been smoothed with a
smooth stone most likely
it's not just one or two pieces of
tutankhamun era pottery
jennifer's team is revealing that the
layers of earth beneath the fortress are
packed full of it
we have new kingdom material under the
floors of rooms 20 19 26 18 and 17. but
to have the fort now documented on top
of deposits that indicate some kind of
occupation in the new kingdom and that's
really exciting
the discovery is proof the site may have
been used in tutankhamun's time by his
gold workers
but the team have found another
remarkable clue concealed in the
fortress
cutting into the bedrock 60 feet below
the surface is a well
it's a vital source of water that
explains why the safe haven and
tutankhamun's gold workers were here
the world was built the time of
tutankhamen by the evidence we have now
it was uh i guess more precious than
even than gold for people that that they
can
have water to go inside inside the
desert
the evidence here and at other sites
reveals how tutankhamun got his gold
from the remote eastern desert
miners had to trek vast distances from
the nile valley across the hot dry
desert to reach the gold mines
ancient engineers dug wells along the
route for precious drinking water
each well was a day's walk from the last
creating a network of vital rest stops
this allowed them to survive the brutal
journey across the desert to mine gold
in the east and bring it back to their
pharaoh
thomas and jennifer have revealed one of
tutankhamun's secrets
sites like this were a critical part of
the infrastructure that allowed him to
amass the gold for one of the most
elaborate burials in history
the golden tuts mask all that gold in
his tomb that's coming from the eastern
desert episode sites like this that
looked really modest are actually the
mechanism that allowed new kingdom gold
to be mine
[Music]
you